well in the case of a book that was in
the back of my mind for as long as this
one 20 years and yet I didn't write that
last sentence until january 2005 from
the moment i got that last sentence and
i began that roadmap we've talked about
and from the moment i started writing
the actual novel august of that same
year two thousand five the writing of
the first draft was rather quickly
forthcoming for me very quickly
unusually quickly but certainly more of
my years as a writer are always spent
rewriting than they are writing first
drafts because i never begin a first
draft until there is a plot until i do
know what happens to all of the
characters you might understand why
those first drafts are pretty quickly
forthcoming but the rewriting process
slows me down and I I like everything
about the writing process that compels
me to slow down to keep it slow I right
all my first drafts in longhand because
you can only write so fast in longhand
and on a keyboard you just you can cover
too much ground in too fast a time right
and I like to keep it slow especially in
that first draft stage and the longer
the book you write the more times you
must pass through it because a writer's
voices change within a four or five year
period of time you're actually liking a
different kind of sentence five years
down the road than you were four years
ago and you one of the one of the tasks
of revising a novel of any length is to
go back and make the whole thing sound
as if it were spoken in one breath as if
your sentence style your preference for
the semicolon or the parentheses or the
dash just was constant and you got to
make it look that way even though it
wasn't spoken in one breath it was
spoken in very halting little bits it's
supposed to sound
like it's coming right off the top of
your head